so hibernate hey I loved loved loved
capital letters and of the movie and I
actually can't wait to go see it again
another time sometimes it's so much did
you feel nervous about bringing Brigitte
back and stepping into our kids in heels
yeah a little bit I just love her so
much I don't want to mess it up but you
definitely did it thank you and join
your time away from Brigitte what did
you miss the most about her I didn't
have to because people come up to me all
the time and want to talk about their
Bridget Jones experiences how neat is
that that is so cool everybody's got a
Bridget Jones moment it's cool it's
really cool and did you watch any of the
old films before like the new ones it
says us refresh your memory unlike some
of the things you used to do yes and
even at the book I just love everything
and so I feel like people can finally
rest easy now we have closure about
Bridget Jones and how her life is do you
feel that way that you've got closure
and you secretly pleased that you won't
be like time again are you bringing in
Bridget back oh I don't know I don't
know that that's the case I like where
she is at her life at this point I like
how she's matured I like the choices
that she makes I like that she's still
hopelessly romantic and messy I love
that she's still so imperfect and
authentic but who knows where it goes
you know you make me excited I could be
a Bridget Jones for maybe I don't know
and so I love that Bridget cut like way
more powerful in the time that she was
crying like she's walking her dog big
time and I just loved that she was dead
careers in bosey when you really excited
but for that element of V and script yes
I think it's essential you know because
as we mature we do and become a little
bit more professionally accomplished you
know she was a total Baba yeah and if
you could write a letter to a younger
Bridget from the first film maybe what
advice would you give her now like
Bridget - Bridget I wouldn't
I wouldn't I know that's so terrible
that means you have to go through all of
those life it's ready yeah because
there's my peepee we want to share it
with her you know I wanna watch her you
know and then progresses and you had
them to sex scenes and this may be
looking you what's it bears Patrick and
Kannan bring to the table did either
bring snacks or lols like when a funny
what would a funny thing to do we could
take this question a lot of different
direction
no they're both sweet they're very sweet
and we laugh a lot and so you know the
shared awkwardness is not horrifying as
you can imagine that it might be yeah
it's so awkward I mean I want my mommy
though Thursday but you know yeah yes so
your rap skills but very impressive
indeed innocent in this film
good we will we be seeing you in a
carpool karaoke anytime soon everything
that's very funny I haven't written an
album so I think that everyone will be
spared that that that torture I think
st. affords I'm gonna love it he's so
great person what do you think bridget
ultimately teaches women about love oh
that's really good yeah I don't know
about love that may be what works on
paper isn't necessarily what will make
you happy what other people expect you
should have might not necessarily be
what's right for you yeah I'm excited
about and a whole load of like like new
fans like maybe people that I've never
even seen a Bridget Jones maybe if they
even assist you talk about plenty I
don't think they are they cute your
delivery about really unforgettable you
excited that people will be coming to
see the film and that would be great
I mean that would be great I would love
that it would make me smile come you
know we were hoping that that the film
wouldn't depend on people's nostalgia
for the other two films in order to be
worthwhile
so that
made me really happy